eh bien oui daniel laurin qui est avec
nous on ce vendredi en cette veille de
longue fin de semaine et quoi de mieux
que de nous proposer de la lecture
bonjour daniel mangeas alors vous nous
parler de deux bouquins aujourd'hui on
va tout d'abord commencé par un auteur
québécois que connut un immense succès
l'ags et un souci qui malheureusement
très jeune et qui lance et dont les
éditions sont son éditeur lance un livre
à titre posthume 30 centimes en fait il
est mort à 54 ans l'été dernier d'une
crise cardiaque ou travaillaient encore
à cet ouvrage là c'est un livre vraiment
fascinant assez différent de ce qu'on
connaît de gaétan soucy dans un sens
évidemment on pense tout de suite à la
petite fille qui aimait trop les
allumettes qu'a été son grand succès un
livre étrange où se
réinventer le langage wii qui a été
traduit dans une vingtaine de langues
qui a reçu des prix ici mais qui est
insensé entre autres en france par la
critique donc c'est très différente dans
le style mais je voudrais il aborde des
thèmes qu'on connaît déjà dans n'oublie
pas s'il te plaît que je t'aime donc ce
livre qui paraît à titre posthume mais
question entre autres de gémellité de
quête de l'absolu mais ici on est
vraiment sur le ton de les teams
d'ailleurs c'est toi c'est toi livre qui
est écrit un peu comme une
lettres d'amour oui c'est exactement ça
c'est une longue lettre d'amour où un
homme qui est en fait un écrivain
reconnu qui est un professeur dans un
collège comme l'était gaétan soucy écrit
une lettre d'amour évidemment on fait
des rapprochements autobiographique on
le voit un peu comme une lettre
testament et ça crée une certaine
fascination pour ce qu'on lit mais en
même temps je voudrais un certain
trouble alors cet homme-là qui s'appelle
philippe dans le livre écrit une lettre
à une jeune étudiante de 18 ans il est
follement amoureux d elle elle l'a
quitté on ne sait pas pourquoi et donc
il veut comprendre pourquoi il a quitté
surtout il veut la convainquent qu'ils
ont une relation exceptionnelle veut la
faire changer d'idée et c'est une lettre
fiévreuse allumé désespéré ça tourne à
l'obsession au délire c'est vraiment
parcours sur le monsieur exactement et
souci avait commencé à écrire une lettre
réplique danse mettant dans la peau de
la jeune fille pour lui répond
malheureusement il n'a pas pu
approfondir cette lettre on a demandé à
d'autres écrivains d'écrire une réplique
à la lettre c'est assez étrange comme
sensation
mais je voudrais l'écriture quand elle
de soucis nous c'est une beauté trajet
on sent sa fragilité ses magnifiques
rapidement d'ailleurs il sa place à
guettant souci de l'allitération écouter
quand il a publié la petite fille qui
aimait trouille les allumettes on a
parlé entre autres d'une comparaison à
réjean ducharme à cause de l'inventivité
du langage à cause de l'exploration de
l'enfance et en france d'ailleurs on a
dit que sont le conte le comparer aux
grands écrivains français de l'absurde
parce qu'il a inventé un langage à
l'intérieur même du langage on va
terminer en parlant d'un grand auteur
américain l'emploi et on a décidé de
regrouper quatre de ses livres à
l'intérieur d'une édition oui un des
grands écrivains américains vivant âgé
de 81 ans qui a dit il ya deux ans qu'il
n'écrirait plus qu'il ne publierait plus
de romain alors c'est l'intention c'est
le moment de le lire ou de le relire
quatre livres importants qui tous
parlent de l'amérique donc le titre
c'est l'ami risque de fait les prop
parle de l'amérique mais de façon très
critique des toujours en entremêlant
cynique je vous dirais et il entremêle
les destins collectifs et individuels
alors il ya pastorale américaine qui se
passe pendant la guerre du vietnam il ya
j'ai épousé un communiste à l'époque du
maccarthysme coche la tâche qui je pense
est si grand livre adapté au cinéma avec
anthony hopkins qui jouait un professeur
qui était accusée injustement de racisme
et il ya une sorte de politique fiction
le complot contre l'amérique près plus
de mille pages de quoi se délecter on va
tous les ans au cours des prochains
trois jours